alejandra on twitter says I saw you
tweet about extended warranties why
wouldn't you buy one well let me help
you with the numbers on an extended
warranty folks twelve percent of the
typical extended warranty whether it's
electronics computers cars twelve
percent
covers the statistical probability of
the item breaking so if one thousand air
conditioners are covered by an extended
warranty
twelve percent of the money paid in for
extended warranties is paid back out to
cover the repairs on the one thousand
air conditioners or whatever item you
want to put in that front in that
sentence the rest goes to salaries
overhead profit the majority of it goes
in a marketing fee to the organization
selling the extended warranty in most
cases well over half so if you buy a
$1500 extended warranty and add it into
your finance plan on your car the
dealership likely made seven hundred
thousand dollars on that and on average
your repair on that would be a hundred
and eighty dollars on average during the
covered repair during the time the
warranty is on there out of fifteen
hundred dollars on average you're going
to receive a benefit of one hundred
eighty dollars that's the national
averages so what we're saying here is is
the reason people sell extended
warranties at best buy at your car
dealer with your heating and air company
and so on the reason people sell
extended warranties is because they make
a bundle on them in commissions you
can't buy a freaking pencil at Best Buy
without them pitching you an extended
warranty I mean I bought an iPhone
case a piece of rubber for goodness
sakes and they wanted to give me a
warranty on it you can't buy anything
because they make more money at Best Buy
on extended warranties and on your
finance plan where you take 90 days same
as cash no paid off in 80 days than they
do on the sale of stuff they don't make
a lot of money on this they don't that
they actually the TVs and the stuff at
Best Buy
all right the you know that those type
of big-box electronic stores that you
know the washer and dryer there there is
not a lot of margin in those things they
don't make a lot of money on they make
more on the extended warranties and on
the credit around it than they do on the
actual merchandise in other words
they're an extended warranty store that
sells financing oh and they happen to
have some electronics mathematically
that's where they make their money in
other words so for you the consumer or
for me the consumer if we self insure
through that item breaking down instead
of spending fifteen hundred dollars we
have the average expense of a hundred
and eighty let's say we have eight an
expense that is twice the average oh
three times the oh four times the whole
five times the average we have five
times as the thing breaks down five
times more than the average thing does
you still come out with half your money
five times
think about it you still come out so
you're spending a bunch of money that
you're not getting anything for it it's
a really horrible set of mathematics
very profitable for the company selling
it somewhat profitable for the extended
warranty company and a horrible product
for you this is a win win lose
proposition so that's why I don't buy
extended warranties if you
can't ensure if you don't have the cash
to fix the item or replace the item when
it breaks past normal manufacturers
warranties beyond normal manufacturers
warranties then they're there but then
don't buy it if you can't afford a two
hundred dollar repair on a car you can't
afford to buy a car you're buying a
twenty five thousand dollar car and you
can't buy for two hundred dollar repair
on it you shouldn't be buying that car
well what if everything blows up yeah
what if everything blows up it doesn't
statistically because statistically if
they let's say that you took out a
fifteen hundred dollar warranty and on
average the average person with the
fifteen hundred dollar warranty
collected sixteen hundred dollars that
means the warranty company received
fifteen hundred and they had to pay out
sixteen hundred how long before they're
out of business twenty minutes it's
called losing money stupid they're not
going to stay open by definition they
have to be making a profit of some kind
to even stay open but in this case
they're making a lot more than that and
the company selling it is actually
making more than the warranty company is
making usually big-time money so hope
that helps you understand why I've never
invoked I've never endorsed since extend
warranties now I'm talking about the
ones you pay for now if there's a
warranty furnished with an item that's
fine but you everybody's looking for
safety and looking for guarantees the
only people that get safety and
guarantees are those are the money to
cause it to happen
meaning that you you know you can
control some variables in your life with
your emergency fund it makes everything
not be an emergency all of a sudden hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]